welcome to this video on playing Gstaad
2014 I only played him played him a
couple of days ago I don't really
remember the game I know the name I
remember the name but not the game okay
let's see go with the h3 line
it's h3 line but not with with the
trading on e5
that's not not bad the trade on your
five but I'd like to have a bit bit of a
sharper position here for the 15 minute
game a bit more bit more fun does not
hurt okay yeah you can do that eg form
g4 as some often a good idea to to play
against his future at 5:00 break this
whole setup is some design - yeah - to
kill off blacks counter play from the
get-go this Eve pawns on e4 and g4
should stop f5 or make it difficult to
play a 5 and if black is not able to
play a 5 then he has a hard time in this
position as it is the only break b6p 6
is a mistake a real mistake the problem
with this move is that it weakens the
light squares here like b5 and c6 these
are now weaker and it it makes it more
difficult for him to play c6 this is
another break that he has c6 now he only
has a 5
the only break left and I don't think he
will manage to play that let's see I can
even think about Bishop d3 here covering
f5 we get once more look g1 is also most
so that f5 is not possible due to the
capture and they take on h6 yeah and
Bishop d3 sometimes also h4 is a move so
that after f5 I can play h5 here however
that's f4 trapping the bishop so this is
something to avoid
I think our player should be three it's
it's rare that you can can do that
because some normally black has played
Knight c5 earlier so this the squares
controlled if he goes at five now I'm
just going to take them yes yeah okay
I don't want to give up the dark squared
Bishop this piece is too important
let's see now there is a change in the
position as on c5 there is a piece that
I can capture so that after f5
I know it's paradoxical I just said I
don't want to capture but if he plays f5
and his intention is to play a four it's
not winning a piece anymore as I can
take on c5 this is some an important
resource as if you think about f5 for
example takes GF GF and Queen h4 h5 I'm
attacking f6 and getting the Queen oh
that's a drastic means he wants to
prevent h4 this lame
now there's there are many ways to play
against that Queen f3 assembles keeping
an eye on f5
well then maybe Nagi fire from know this
is something I must avoid but what about
Knight f3 isn't he just going back then
what I'm thinking about is after Knight
f3 Queen yeah I don't really believe
Queen f6 yes that's good so he must
something do something like that and
then I thought Queen d2
how does he protect how does he protect
the pawn on h6 I probably doesn't I
think he must play g5 that's really
horrible let's let's do that
maybe he still must play a five to get
to get something something going here
if I can just take aged six without any
particular bad thing happening to me
it's a it's very very good so let's
check f5g fgf Bishop h6 it takes a form
this is maybe a line but I have rook g1
threatening threatening on g7 and if he
covers it I can take K key form yeah
that's already a very bad position
probably yeah this is this this line
with h3g form it does not leave black
much room for four half moves or
semi-decent moves that it's really tough
b6 was hmm so and so really a really a
mistake and now Knight in our Queen age
form okay what now that that's an
interesting spot here if he gets if he
gets enough time to get night f-86 to f4
then this is not even so bad what I'm
wondering is can I quickly open up the
King side what do I need to need to
spend spend time on that hmm like a long
castle
Luke moves up G one night f8 but then I
play h4 and black explodes yeah that
that's enough I don't need to do any
fancy stuff
I just have the a form break h4 break h4
not a form and yeah but what you can try
yeah but not really
I thought maybe Knight f6 could could be
could be an idea to put some pressure on
the g4 point so that h4 is not so easily
possible but it's it's it does not work
any at all Knight f6 I still play h4
energy for that take on g5 this is this
is really exploding okay
yes tillage fryer okay now here is
everything's controlled the thing is
what about on what about the Queen side
okay I need to I need to cover cover c4
anyway and maybe get the knight back to
the tool this is this is not doing much
on f3 now anyway
the question is how do I handle this
pawn structure on the Kings side you
know there is one one very reliable
method this is going to go h5 and just
close it down but it's this is a bit
lame I take it it's not that it is not
helping really okay let's do that first
the thing is of course the idea is 92 f1
g3 I don't see him ever taking on h4
this is simply never possible
this also be form as an idea ultimately
this will switch to the Queen side
anyway that's not the best move h5 but
that's just imagine I would play h5
close it down and then play before at
the end our breakthrough on the Queen
side there's no doubt about it it's just
a matter of time yeah let's go before as
good maybe he's trying to play c6 now
but note that this b6 move always leads
to a position where I capture where the
d5 squares is really weak c6 without b6
is entirely different
okay so f5 s
the aim for the night so let's see you
should I now combine this with the
queenside
I guess if I play before take stakes or
okay one day he will exchange one pair
of rooks and I don't want want him to
allow any exchanges can I can invest
this this one move here okay so right
it's not clear if Knight a5 is really
leading too much you will take it and I
don't think I have have gained so much
if I play before and he takes a bab
night a six maybe maybe you can do that
get the night over to before yeah okay
that's that's not brilliant but maybe
you can do that okay it still should
should should help me yeah
over to before okay let's see how to
combat that
now maybe yes c5 but take Knight takes
Knight to d4 but okay it's light squares
are so terribly weak cannot really be
cannot really help them okay
I'm not afraid that he takes my bishop I
mean I have a I have a I have a soft
spot for bishops that's clear but what
I'm what I'm trying to do is to to
attack this piece with Queen d2 and the
knight move or Bishop d2 when the knight
move I don't want to give him the
opportunity to exchange it ideally he
needs to retreat it and then it's on on
this basic square
let's see what he's doing
91 III to f5 yeah this is a one one way
to go
be one the bishop on the one of course
is also covering a twosome
rook a to and and this kind of moves are
not possible very difficult for him can
hardly move what what he can try to do
and but he does not do a for a couple of
moves is try to move the f8 rogue and
play Knight FA 2 G 6 not fh g 6f for
this would be a positional threat and
maybe then I'm compelled to okay is
retreating voluntarily
okay back to c5 okay yeah maybe just I
mean I'm not forced to do anything here
I can also get back to rook a1 the rook
a one idea if he plays rook night a six
now again going for before I play look
at one and it's a really nasty pin and
maybe I'm threatening before maybe
yeah after before he probably
okay let's say let's think about this
after before where's he going night a
for I take with the bishop bishop takes
and then Knight f5 and I have got B
fiver so this is a disaster
he must go back to a6 and then
everything like before if I don't know
it's it's very very good right be five
or maybe even King b3 I can't even do
that one night a 691 to e3
I only must be cautious that I'm not
playing this to artificially and at some
point he he can open up the Queen side
to his favor I mean I don't mind the
Queen side to open to open but not with
my king and the fire I need to do this
slowly okay oh this is another square
but it's not a very good one where do
you go from there okay so it's no 91 or
and to e3 yeah okay
if he tries to double on the a file I
have Bishop b3 again
yeah this type of position as the reason
why I usually don't play the the pure
classical Kings Indian where often black
gets some type of a tech going and you
yeah you sometimes need to defend very
accurately and in in those type of lines
where you have not Castle short you
sometimes get this type of position
where quite often it is just a matter of
some precision and you win almost
automatically if black is playing a
somewhat second-rate setup like it
happened here okay so Bishop d3 m2 to
keep b5 he he made this sacrifice to
open up the Queen side
so I'm ready for 93 to f5 and also I can
just go to back to 23 to cover here but
it's not necessary okay right I mean I
can I can head towards a 5 finally okay
I didn't really see them maybe I should
have okay let's so let's let's open up
now even if he gets B 5 that's not
that's not fatal
so nighty to f5 probably this should be
fine threatening to take g7 and
ninety-five again if he takes on b5 okay
if I now take on g5 he will catch on
these three and capture on before this
is not this is not really good so I must
probably take
yeah Queen takes I mean even the and
probably need to trade queens it's not
it's not a problem I mean this is still
very dominating I have various ways to
win pawns iam not not sure if this is
good ninety seven ninety five take aged
six maybe but taking this Bishop on g7
is really not not what you want to do
it's such a bad piece
hmm it surprised I'm overlooking
something
I mean look takes rook takes looks
extremely strange yeah okay so just the
Queen trade on I don't think I have
something better really and it's just a
good position it's not not necessary to
do anything fancy I'm just wondering
what about rook c1 here
how does he protect probably look p7
okay rook a seven I could have taken
take drug takes is a group text see 796
takes on b5 okay one one thing is I
would like to take the night here but on
the other hand before hang so I must be
I must be cautious hmm but he's not
really threatening much does he does not
take threatened to take here for example
so maybe just just route back I can take
g7 and play Knight f5 and win the ACE to
h6 pawn but I'm not sure I don't want to
serve this night for against the bishop
for just one pawn it's not it's not
looking right no let's let's get get on
the iPhone and to keep the pressure on
I would like to take as mentioned this
would be but if I would have taken
before I can take on on before and
that's not entirely clear if you please
look okay look b8 maybe I could have
taken but he cannot now he cannot
prevent that really but okay the first
the other moves that is threatening
asuke age yeah
look ahead
so what snow yeah should I take it
hmm yeah I guess I can I can take it
Knight h5 maybe right Age 5 maybe Bishop
e7 as a defense ok I have I have all the
time in the world
don't don't need to rush anything here
mm I know all first King up yeah
I can't even think about b5 not I'm not
so sure about it
hmm let's think that think about it
Knight h5 is not not bad at all but that
it lacks a bit of punch well what is he
moving if I do that
look b6 night b7
maybe I wonder if I should regroup this
Knight to a5 and to c6 would be would be
excellent ok let's try that if he plays
c6 ok
okay I want to prevent if prevent c6
it's probably not good but I mean good
for black not good for black but let's
prevent it anyway
okay the the I want to put it on c6
another good plan is maybe look a 3 H 3
H 7 also very very tough to to defend
you have the night arriving only 5 s
almost a complete zugzwang
rook H rook G H is no interesting but if
I if I arrive on c6 ins and so it's all
very nice so this is completely
paralyzed the look will never move so
what is what is exactly isn't so much
super strong
you can only move Ruby 7 to b6 switching
over now threatening look f7 black yeah
it's really a bit of a statistical game
now here but but this is the way it is
played what can you do this can easily
happen this type of position of black
does not get any counter to play against
this efore g4 watch and he he made some
positional mistakes
b6 b6 is a mistake really it at the end
look at the end the whites where's a
light squares were the problem and I
don't think that that after that he can
get a satisfactory position anymore
Queen f6 is the computer suggestion and
he wants it wants to play Queenie tomb
okay yeah maybe this move was
technically interesting because Keaney
to this oops
there's Bishop a6 this is not so not so
convincing maybe yeah but even here what
what are you doing after b3 I'm
threatening on h6 and just as this is a
disaster here I can both captures
capture is good and this is also good
and this is quite funny for example a
human player will easily assess this
position as almost strategically winning
for white well the computer in this case
stockfish only sees 0.7 for white which
is far too low it's it's almost a win if
white plays it precisely because black
has absolutely no counter play the
kingside is sealed
I have the possibility to put a knight
on a five it's a bit it's not too far
from the game if you look at this in the
game I had the additional option to open
the age file and this is why I didn't
play Age 5 but even with age 5 it would
have been would have been absolutely
overwhelming around here there were many
many possibilities
I could also win pawns I mean but I
don't want to hear you can you can take
and take here that's also good maybe
this is really good to be honest you
don't need the dark squared bishop
anymore with this thing incarcerated
yeah but okay I just played it in the
most methodical fashion on the queenside
and yes absolutely no play yeah you sort
of want to win with the mating attack
but this is just just so bad
okay this was one way to play it with
this total Zeus one and here he has no
move this rook takes f7 threatened and
cannot move Knight has no square Bishop
has no square can go Ruka b6 but yeah I
even have that yeah that's that's it
it's really terrible alright thanks for
watching